one of my favorite actors of all time is
also one of my favorite characters of
all time
from one of my favorite shows of all
time its Peter Dinklage as Tyrion from
Game of Thrones
one of the great aspects about this show
is that it loves to take people that in
the world this series has created would
most likely be found dead very quickly
the little people the children the women
but instead many of them seized power
relying on their cunning wit and create
some unforgettable characters my
favorite one being Tyrion this is a guy
who knows his disadvantage and as he
puts it wears it as a badge because once
you embrace it nobody can harm you with
it true he was born into a royal family
but not only was he born as a little
person in a time period where they could
get no respect whatsoever but his birth
also caused the death of his mother
leaving much anger in his father the
king so he was cast aside and seen as
not important in many respects he abused
his authority taking advantage of whores
alcohol and so forth
but on the other hand he also used the
advantages he had to grow smarter listen
to the common people of the world and
became both book wise and streetwise
turning him into probably the most
intelligent person in the entire show
not only does he know it but he exploits
it like mad the second season in
particular is the season of Peter
Dinklage when his father the king
finally sees that he has this incredible
intelligence he assigns him to be the
hand of the king giving him unbelievable
power that only does he use it to make
strategic choices against his enemies
but he uses it to make strategic choices
against his enemies in his own house no
one threatens his grace in the presence
of the Kingsguard I'm not threatening
the Kings I am educating my nephew Bronn
the next time ser Meryn speaks kill him
that was a threat see the difference
anyone he doesn't trust their asses
grass anyone doing wrong in the world
they're gone he would lie manipulate and
cheat all for the purpose of ironically
returning some honor and dignity to a
very corrupt Kingdom
he just owns it and I'm not gonna lie
even though the character is written
wonderfully so much of it does just come
from the performance Peter Dinklage is
just unbelievable all the actors in Game
of Thrones are but I think again by the
fact that this character has probably
the biggest disadvantage against him at
least in this time period and totally
turning it around to being the most
awesome person in the entire series is
really quite an achievement he may be
short but nobody walks taller and nobody
deserves it more even when he has a
chance to run away and live a happy life
somewhere else he finds that he can't
because he enjoys the intellectual
intrigue of the world around him even if
he knows he most likely will be killed
for it
but he knows this is who he is and if he
ran away from it he would die just
slower and even less happy at the very
least he could perish doing what he
loves being a smart bastard trying to
play everyone else against each other
and soaking in the joys that he's the
one that put it together
he's so diabolical and yet always doing
it for the right reasons he knows he's
in a bad evil world he's lived in that
bad evil world he's been the victim of
that bad evil world but if he could give
some comeuppance to the people who made
that bad evil world it suddenly seems a
little more tolerable the series is not
even over yet and I just adore this guy
I haven't read the books I don't know
where it's gonna go and I want to
continue to be surprised he's the best
part of the best show